so look at the words you use like i can
handle the emotional abuse and whatever
it is like
yeah and people might describe you it's
like i know she's awesome she's tough
would probably be a word and you look at
your career
and the fact that you're competing
against guys and in a sport that is
you know all of the things right like
that speaks to somebody whose persona
has become you know very robust but that
doesn't speak to what's beneath it
when you recognize that you have
feelings right and i'm not talking in a
woo-woo kind of kumbaya
but you're a sentient being you're a
woman you know an
extraordinary woman and an accomplished
woman and a caring woman
and the degree to which all of that gets
kind of pushed to one side because you
can handle the abuse
as i tell people just because it's
familiar doesn't mean it's healthy right
totally yeah i believe that each and
every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools
to make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense well i have to
say
that this is definitely gonna go down so
far as the most
vulnerable interview i've done the most
raw
interview if you stick with it you will
hear and
peter crone is the guest today i didn't
know what i was getting myself into
but it was a huge episode for me
but also for i think just the collective
experience understanding and witnessing
of the human dynamic the human emotion
what being human and perhaps what we're
here to do
looks like sometimes it's not always
pretty however i
it's uh you know peter's belief and mine
as well that we're here to grow and
evolve
and growing and evolving requires
looking at all aspects of ourselves to
become
healed and whole but but hopefully it
will show you
yourself in a way to know that this is
part of the journey and it's okay to to
go to these places that are
are really vulnerable and raw and and
step into your healing
everyone has an opinion and especially
when you're
you know i find that when we start
talking about foundational things like
religion politics what like
how you treat your body like all of
those things that are really
foundational
there's so much cognitive dissonance
around shifting
or changing their mind because to me
it's like they're
it's the house of cards for them if they
have to think differently
choose differently um change their mind
what else does it and so it's more of a
subconscious thing but what else does it
imply
it's a direct threat to someone's
identity that's the trouble
right it's like you know i mean i can go
deep down the rabbit hole of
any of those but religion for example
like which rubs people perhaps the wrong
way but
no one on the planet is christian no one
right they may subscribe to the tenants
of christianity
that's a very different it's semantic
but it's incredibly important because
to me why why i'm not into religion so
much is it tends to create diversity
right it
creates division so when a baby's born
the baby doesn't even know its own name
it doesn't know it's gender it certainly
doesn't know what religion apparently
ascribes to
so to declare that i am something i am
is the root
you know that is the precursor to how we
define ourselves
right so it's not wrong it's just
inaccurate you know
like to say i'm muslim i'm buddhist i'm
christian
it's not wrong it's just inaccurate it's
not a truth but as soon as you become
collapsed with it's no different than
someone saying i'm fat
that equally isn't true but as soon as
you become identified with the words
that
follow the i am then you think that's
who you are and you're going to defend
it which is why you know there's so much
bloodshed
so um that's where i have issue with any
of that you know whereas
as soon as we declare something
certainly that has been uh
generational like you know if your
parents were this and that whatever it
might be
your parents could be overweight and now
i'm overweight like it doesn't have to
be specific to religion
it's just whatever we inherit in the way
that we define ourselves
then anything that is in contrast to
that or conflict
to it is going to meet resistance
and that's where it gets ugly so what is
the correct
use of i am well it's about as far as
you can go
asking a question no there's i am like
that's it
right like it's i mean we're going down
deep here but when i really got that
i am what more do i need was one of my
quotes right so
i i'm sure you're familiar with my work
that's how it comes through me is these
short
quotes and insights and i see i really
got to the point of where i shared so
many of the different levels of who i
thought i was and all the different
layers of my particular persona
that i got to i am what more do i need
and within i am is everything
which of course it starts to become
esoteric but i am nurse
is consciousness god love whatever you
want to call it to me the absolute so i
am is all potentialities
then we declare who we are on top of
that so that's why i love
you know working with actors over the
years because they do this for a career
right they
they pretend to be somebody tom hanks
wasn't gay and dying of hiv but he
played that in philadelphia
so he could say i am whatever his
character was michael but he knows when
he goes home that
he's straight and he's married and
apparently not dying of aids right so
he's pretending
the trouble is the persona that we take
on from a very young age is still a
pretense it's just we do it for three
four five decades
so we think that's who we are as opposed
to remembering
no i'm all i'm all possibilities but
i've declared myself in such a way and
often it's not a choice it was something
that was given to me
you're being told by a parent you're
being told by a teacher this is who you
are
you're a failure you're not good enough
and then we adopt that
and that becomes the mental prison and
then people live in the
for the majority of their lives so well
i like to pull both sides of the
spectrum right so
you've got the i am a victim i am sick i
am
you know miserable i am fat i am ugly
whatever
i am danica but could we not reframe
this in a way that is
of equal strength and power in a
positive way like i am well
i mean i feel actually i feel so i feel
so wayne dyer right now
right um the i am that i am discourses
or whatever
i think is a book maybe you wrote um but
i am well
like i am happy i am successful like i
am peaceful
yeah can we not use it the other is
there a way to use
i am a hundred percent that's just the
root
you know so for sure this is you know my
work is dissolution i don't say i solve
people's problems i dissolve them so
what i'm dissolving is the
the the current attachment to the i am
that tends to
to veer towards the derogatory the
deleterious the negative the limited
but then yes once you remove that you
step back into
what we could say as this realm of all
opportunities pure potential
and then through declaration we get to
say something else so yes
i am extraordinary like one of my
favorite athletes who
actually is just he's an mlb player we
worked together for
six seasons he had five six all-stars in
a row just
incredible success and it was just so
fun to work together
he took a couple years off and he just
i've spoke to him this morning so he's
asked to work with me again this season
and one of my favorite conversations
with him
he was he was pretty relentless as an
athlete super disciplined
incredibly determined and one of the
words
we played with as a declaration was
unstoppability what does that look like
especially in baseball it's a game of
failure right like three out of ten and
you're an all-star like that's that's
not good
ratio right to be 30 percent and yet
you're an all-star
speaks to how much failure there is in
the game as a hitter
so anyway i asked him the question i
said so what why are you unstoppable
and he came up with you know all of
these incredibly valid responses well
you know i'm
i'm dedicated i put in the work reasons
that justify
being unstoppable but because of the
virtue by virtue of our conversation and
how i worked with him i said well those
aren't wrong they're not inaccurate but
what i'm asking you to look at is
you're unstoppable because you say so
and he still to this date cites that
conversation he's like
wow like it's a declaration of who i be
who i am that is the container that i
step
within that shows up the discipline and
the dedication and the professionalism
it's not because of those things i
declare myself to be unstoppable
and then i honor my word which is really
the power of language so why i use the
expression words of the wardrobe for the
soul
so our soul is limitless but by virtue
of the words we use it will
contain whatever is potential it creates
the limitations invariably because most
people's words are
like you said limited but once we remove
that constraint then we get to declare
words that are more expansive
so for me i say like i'm i'm the
luckiest human being on the planet
now where's the evidence for that other
than my declaration to it which then
becomes self-fulfilling
it's really it pulls for the the
opportunity
for me to vibrate and feel at a certain
level but then also
the magic of how life can show up by
virtue of that frequency that i hold
because of the declaration i make
yeah words are yeah words are words are
spells spelling
it's in the word spelling abracadabra
abracadabra isn't that what it isn't
what is that the hebrew translation as i
speak so i create
magic i just got back from egypt so i
feel like
totally true yeah why
it seems so much easier and i'm speaking
from experience
it seems so much easier or at least
much more routine to judge let's just
even say myself
yeah and speak negatively like you know
untethered soul i think it was was like
you'd never be friends with your inner
your inner self like the the things that
you say to yourself like would you ever
be best friends with that person no
we're so hard on ourselves
right um why the heck are we programmed
like that or is this
are we pro i mean why are we hard on
ourselves why would we do that
it's a great question i get it in
different iterations of that i would
assert it's because that's the dimension
we're in
right so for me from my perspective
because looking at the deepest level of
who we are these limitless spiritual
energetic beings and we've manifested
into this physical meat suit
on a place called planet earth why did
we come here because we had karma to
resolve
and the karma being limitations fears
perceptions of inadequacies
and life one again one of my favorite
quotes a lot of people share is
life will present you with people and
circumstances to reveal where you're not
free
100 so you're always going to attract
whatever it is that you need in order to
be that subtle
sort of form of resistance and sloughing
to be able to remove the constraints
that currently inhibit the
limitlessness of your soul right and
this paradigm is perfect for that
so the language that we use that you
cite
is derogatory by virtue of the fact
that's still how we look at ourselves
and it's flip it's it's twofold so
that's how we incarnate like i say we
arrive with our bucket of fears and the
game is who can get rid of them the
first
you know the quickest then you become an
inspiration for other people to do the
same
but really it's also without the
constriction
of self-judgment or self-criticism you
don't actually have to learn the
language of love
see it's easy to love the parts of you
that you love it's easy to love the
parts of you that you like or that you
find attractive
but love that is
is able to embrace all of the parts of
you that you think are ugly
is love see love doesn't distinguish
between forms
and so going back to how we sort of
prior to this was talking about love
love that is based on you know well you
do what i want you to do
then i love you that's that's not love
that's conditional dependency
that's preferences yeah so ironically by
virtue of the fact that we have these
narratives and the dialogues about
ourselves that are
derogatory then that part of us
is actually the conduit to which we get
to manifest
what real love is which is being able to
embrace all parts
do we actually ever experience anyone
else
or do we only really actually experience
ourselves and our wounds
our triggers our insecurities our
judgments
are our do we only ever experience
ourselves
i know that's like i'm actually jumping
into a concept that's probably
a little too complicated if you haven't
even
like gone there as far as mirroring
triggers projections
wounds try like right so maybe we should
like
back it up before i ask that question do
we ever actually experience anyone else
and like unpack the human experience
okay well that could take a while
um i mean i think the first part of your
question is powerful
it's you know we could argue it depends
how deep you want to go that it's
all us all the way i want to go all the
way okay that's what she said
is this is it all right yeah we say
whatever the hell we want
it's important to make jokes along the
way when we're saying really big words
and talking about really big concepts
because it
is humanizing and relating really big
things uh
yeah she said that too
self-declared um
so yeah so i guess words are so
imperative like so for you to say do we
really experience anybody else we could
say well what do you mean by do we
really experience
right and this is where i think love and
relationships which is something i've
spoken to a lot recently is so
it's so imperative to understand because
if in order to be truly connected with
somebody you have to know how to listen
and most people don't know how to listen
because they're listening through
a filter of self-protection so
invariably most people
aren't able to be with another person
fully
because by virtue of their brain which
is designed to predict and protect
because it's a survival mechanism
then in invariably what's actually
happening at a deeper subconscious level
is
we're looking out for anything that
could be a perceived threat and now
perceived threat doesn't have to be
someone running at us with a knife or a
saber-toothed tie but
tiger it could be somebody saying
something that is in conflict with our
belief structures
so then we feel the need to defend now
what's actually happening in that
interaction is you're not hearing what
they're saying you're hearing your ears
work you hear the sound
but what it is it's coming up against
something that is so primal in the way
that you relate to yourself in life that
it feels like it's a threat at that
moment there's no connection there's no
relationship and this is why most
relationships don't work
because people don't actually listen
particularly sadly the men
women are much better at that and
holding space for each other so i think
the only way that you could truly get
close to experiencing somebody else
is when you really understand what it
means to listen and listening
is similar to it's an akin to love
because you're holding space for someone
to have their reality
regardless of whether you agree with it
condone it or get it
or understand it doesn't matter you're
understanding that that's their current
reality and it's transitory
right like i was in hawaii doing a
retreat
predominantly women and this one mum
very sweet she said you know how do i
help my son who's always speaking
negatively about himself and especially
as it relates to his older brother
he kept saying you know i'm never going
to be as good as jimmy and
and um she would she went on to say you
know i'm telling him he's
all his attributes all of his skills
like no you but you're amazing and
you're this and you're kind and you're
that
and i said but you're not listening to
him and you know it was quite
confronting for her for me to just be
that blatant with her and i said i think
she's doing it right
right she's being a mom and she loves
her son and i got it i understand
her reality but it's a superimposition
of her view on top of his
which is a form of demand and
manipulation
um so she she was amazing she was such a
trooper and i said so i just want you to
consider your son is saying what he's
saying and that's his reality now i
understand you don't want him to hang
out in this world of demise and
insufficiency
but that is his reality and the degree
to which you're not meeting him there is
the degree to which it's being
perpetuated
and she's like oh my god and and she
said you know what's funny he's always
telling me i don't listen
i said well apparently he's pretty
astute you know so
she but it was so powerful she had a
tear in her eye because i said listen
i of course with you want him to feel a
sense of worth and
for his perception relative to his
brother to be enhanced and so that he
doesn't feel inadequate
but until such time that you honor
somebody's reality for where they are
right now
there is no shift there is no
transformation so she really got it she
said wow that's so powerful
then you can get into his world which
would be the closest to getting to
experience somebody and say
well why do you feel that where did that
start what happened
versus you superimposing your view on
someone else's
you she got to have the opportunity to
understand why he felt that way
at the end of our interaction she was
really sporty and you know everybody got
so much from it in the group
which is often the case when i'm working
with someone one-on-one
i said here's my invitation to you
go meet your son and that's when the
you know the tears really started
rolling because she loves him but she
hadn't really met him
the being yeah you know so and she sent
me a beautiful email a couple of
uh weeks after she's like you know our
relationship is
night and day what do we do with someone
who
um like when we look at attachment
styles
and you look at someone who especially
if they're avoidant
and you know you want to have a
conversation you start asking questions
and you're curious and you really want
to get to know them but they don't
share because i feel like that's the
thing right there's
yeah would would it be safe to say that
people generally fall into like either
anxious or avoidant like either they
really jump in and want the information
kind of airing on the codependent side
too
avoidant and disassociative and
more internal is that or maybe you
should tell me like
you're the expert what what kind of
styles of communication are out there
i mean the myriad and i think it really
speaks more to the person who's
listening than the person who's speaking
so by that i mean you know life
pulls for something right like
we tend to be more reactors than
anything as human beings so
yeah i was on a flight i went to speak
to 100 ceos in austin last week
and getting on the flight it's
fascinating to watch the human behavior
of people walking on they see an
attendant
who's got a basket of these sanitizer
wipes
and it's like you know whack-a-mole
watch that video yeah i mean it's just
you know i without being judgmental it
is nonetheless
fascinating to see that what happens is
the hand comes out with the sanitizer
towel
that calls for that pulls for somebody
to grab something
right right now of course there's a back
context here of fear and this is bad and
you know which is all exacerbating what
is a survival instinct for any human
being
but it pulls forth so why that
correlates to your question is
who are you as an individual that pulls
for somebody to be withdrawn or
more self-expressed and and i can
remember talking to one of my managers
for
an mlb team and we had a little incident
in the clubhouse
where one of our sort of all-star
pitchers spoke to the media about
a subject that was clearly really meant
to be in-house
you know sort of in the confines of the
locker room
and so the manager was kind of pissed
you know and upset that this had now
gone through a journalist and was sort
of out there in the public domain
and so he was looking directly at the
picture from the perspective of judgment
and criticism like he is the cause of my
suffering and my frustration which is
how most people react to life right like
i'm upset because of what they did or
what happened
which is all the illusion and i said
okay well i understand where you're
coming from i get you're upset but can i
ask you a few questions
so i could get into his world right so
i'm listening he's like sure i said
tell me a little bit about your
relationship with the pitcher
he's like what do you mean i said well
to what degree do you think
you hold a space that is safe and open
and inviting for him to come to you and
you know he was
kudos to him he was honest he said well
we don't have the best relationship and
you know and i cited a couple of
intro altercations they'd had earlier in
the season he's like yeah i mean i was
pretty hard on him and
whatever and i said so could you see
that perhaps
when it relates to a topic that for him
is heartfelt because it was a sensitive
issue
where is your role in recognizing that
he felt more comfortable talking to a
journalist than he did to you
and that's where he became a better
manager at that moment i said so maybe
your opportunity is to use this as a
catalyst to see that perhaps as a leader
which you are as the manager of this
clubhouse your capacity to listen isn't
as great as perhaps you might
proclaim it to be and you can clean it
up with him and say hey
thank you for showing me that i perhaps
am not the greatest listener for you and
i'd like to change that
so then he became a better leader so
with regards to people being withdrawn
we could say more depressed or somebody
being overly verbose or anxious
i would say yes some of that's generated
by virtue of their conditioning but it's
also based on the environment they're
speaking into
and so that's where people really have
some say in the way that a relationship
goes because we often think well the
relationship i have with that person is
over there with them
you know whether they're a nice person
or a bad person or however you want to
declare it
but the relationship is actually with us
because the way we view someone
is the container within which we
communicate to them so if you're like oh
bob he's awesome you know it's like
you talk to bob from a position of like
that's a human being who's awesome
if you know mary is a pain in my ass
then you speak to mary from that
position but the relationship of
mary exists within our own perception
right
so that's where you start to see and
this goes back full question of you know
full circle to your point about
like how do we experience everyone well
it's all us you know
so like you're awesome because you know
that's how i see you which is really me
so i'm awesome
right but we don't see things as they
are we see things as we are
exactly so yeah it gets it gets it gets
pretty deep i like that we've gone there
straight away here
yeah for sure that's excuse me that's
where we go it's a little chilly out
here
and people don't know but i'm sitting on
a heating pad my butt's kind of tingly
it's like the
um it's like dumb and dumber when he's
like you know here my hands are kind of
sweaty take these extra gloves
you've had two glasses on the back of
the bike this whole time
what does it say about our relationship
and where's the love like you know like
i'm cozy like you're fine
some invitations you've been a real dick
to our guests like we haven't we haven't
started
i'll swap spots with you if you want no
i'm kidding okay all right my butt's
kind of hot though
i've read that article i think she's got
a heart but
i haven't made that today i haven't got
to the dizzy heights of that yet
oh my god um i want to talk about
listening because like
there's got to be more rules to it right
because there's one thing of just sort
of listening
yeah but i can just sit here and listen
to you talk the whole time and say
i listen to you yeah okay there's got to
be more participation
than that to being a good listener right
there's got to be more
to it than just sitting there and
listening is it repeating back
is it asking more questions is it like
how
what is it what is a good listener
so now it's a great question i would
just subtly change again because of
words and we're being specific
you don't got to do anything right
because gotta have to should supposed to
must all of those words carry resistance
like i gotta do this and i gotta do i've
gotta finish my homework and i
must do this and i've gotta like none of
those words are empowering
like they're all disempowering so
there's no gotta and i would say that if
you're listening from a position of that
then you've already put
a barrier because it's sort of an
implied like task
now i have to listen to my mother-in-law
or
i should you know i have to listen to my
boss
so i would sort of get rid of any
resistance first of all and it wants to
be an
action of love i would say and that
would be one of the undercurrents that
is imperative in order to be powerful
listening is that not only am i hearing
like the
the physics of my my my ear sensing
sound but i'm getting what you're saying
that would be the the deeper undertaking
which is to really get
you know because you could start telling
me about something that's troubling in
your life right now
and if i didn't have the undercurrent of
sympathy empathy or the ability to
relate to that
then i might be hearing what you're
saying but i'm not really understanding
the depth of your own pain
so listening is where it's a container a
safe space where i'm also
understanding the depth of your reality
it could be joy it could be misery it
could be heartache it could be grief
and of course i get to do this a lot
because people are telling me whatever's
going on in their life and invariably
invariably if they're coming to see me
it's because things are a bit
problematic it's not always the case
like you know a lot of my athletes and
high performers are thriving but they
know they could go to another level so
it's not necessarily something like some
malaise or their
life isn't this dark place but to be
able to really get
like the the depth of despair that
people feel like really understand how
scared someone is
like that would be sort of listening
x right that would be listening like
where you really are
holding space embodying in your own
experience the degree to which you can
somebody else's reality that's
connection
that's that's resonance so putting
yourself there to some degree
to really to embody means to feel it
right so
going to a place where you felt fear or
you felt sad
yeah to be able to ra relate to them at
that
level of emotion and that's where we
talk about empathy and sympathy and i
think that also comes with
um maturity right it would be very
difficult
my mom died when i was seven it's going
to be very difficult for me as a
seven-year-old to have empathy for my
dad's experience of losing his wife
you know because i don't have the
wherewithal i don't have the bandwidth
to understand i haven't gone through my
own grief of someone who i love dying of
course my mom but
at seven i don't process that as a
seven-year-old so
and i think that's also where there's a
lot of compassion with somebody's
inability to listen like that's just
where they're at
you know and that's a hard pill to
swallow when you're in a relationship
that perhaps where somebody is evolving
and they're a better listener and
perhaps their partner isn't so good
but it also might just point to the fact
that maybe they haven't had so many
experiences
on the sort of the tapestry of human
emotion so they're unable to relate
fully to what someone's going through so
when you go through
experiencing a new emotion as you said
they maybe haven't experienced that
before
are you remembering how it feels or are
you
actually getting the feeling for the
first time let me back up by saying
yeah as a as a as a concept i believe
that
we kind of we are everything
we are the universe within outside so
so within so without as above so below
we're the whole thing
yeah so it's more about remembering the
feeling of familiarity and that
we have we have it inside of us which is
why we can feel it
um so do we actually have to get the ex
like how do we get there how do like you
know what i mean how do we get to
relate to someone
do we actually have to have the
experience um
no i think that could be helpful in
terms of a visceral experience but it
can be just purely
like the sentience the understanding the
resonance of it
so i think it is a remembrance right
like and i think one of the reasons we
have the world of
perceived separation and diversity is
that
you know going deeper again like
what is consciousness right like so
one of my quotes i love that we just get
straight into the deep stuff i say you
know the seeker is the sort
right like which people are going to
have to like s-o-u-g-h-t not so
i was like the sword i'm like trying to
imagine the seeker is the sword
so what the sought the sod the sword
i'm english darling english english
proper english
proper english the queen's english
what's in paris english yeah baby
uh the the seeker is the sort so what
does that mean so
you know the essence of who i am is that
which i
seek so we could say that consciousness
is just wanting to know
itself but and and i had this
as an actual experience when i was my
little rent control apartment in santa
monica this is
you know prior to sort of what i could
say was a big shift i don't want to call
it my awakening that sounds very
pretentious but
where i at least shifted gears in the
way that i related to myself as a human
being
i was just going for a run or just come
back for a run
and i was leaning up against the walls
stretching one of my calves
so you know my foot was back you've done
this i'm sure many times and so my face
is close to the wall so i get a little
bit of an angle and i'm stretching my
achilles
and by virtue of the fact that my face
was so close to the the wall
i felt a little disoriented because
there was no perspective there was no
point of relativity
and a lot of people experience this when
they ski or snowboard when the clouds
are low
and it sort of merges into the same tone
of the snow and you don't have any sort
of point of perspective there's no depth
perception and it becomes very
disorienting even nauseating
and at that moment as i was stretching i
it just gave me the epiphany of my own
quote that
without diversity we don't know oneness
because
oneness doesn't have an experience and
this is why it's so beautiful that it's
set up this way and it looks like you
might have just got something or you're
about to sneeze
or you've got stomach cramps
i have to process internally yeah so so
oneness if you really get it like and
people often especially here in la and
the spiritual groups are like oh we're
all one i'm like
yes but like oneness doesn't actually
know an experience without the we
so that's where i got that moment of
like wow
when i'm up against the wall and
everything for whatever reason it was a
rent control apartment why the paint was
so beautifully uniformed i have no idea
but
it was by virtue of the fact that
clearly my soul called in that
experience that i could go wow
if there isn't any relativity then there
is no relationship if there's no
relationship there's no experience
and so oneness by virtue of its nature
doesn't know itself so it's created
again this is just my
declaration it's created diversity so
that through you and through another i
get to experience so now to come full
circle to your
question it is by virtue of relativity
that i know myself and so experience is
all there
but i get to witness it perhaps through
another who can display it in a way that
i wasn't available
to do so at this time yeah
is that deep enough for you i love that
yeah i love that
and the fact that like i was like
hitting that moment because
duality and oneness are something that
i've thought a lot about in the last
sort of six six to eight months and
in my own personal experiences of
further and further at the ends of the
spectrum
which i felt like duality was just sep
separate events different
things yeah they're of the same hole
meaning like i was always in the middle
of it
like i was experiencing more things in
other ends of the spectrum
and it almost was like as far as much is
as much more pain as i was feeling i was
feeling as much more
joy yes and it was like as i marched
further and further with experiences
further out in each direction
i'm still in the middle and i'm like wow
and then i realized it's all a circle
it's all the same
yeah which is why the you know the
beautiful image of yin and yan right so
that
that represents duality black and white
male and female
but it's contained within the circle
which is the oneness yeah
so which is why it can't know itself i
mean there's also another thing like
listening to alan watts like
you know you he was talking about this
in one of his one of the talks that i
listened to and it was like
you have to have the other one you can't
know it without the other one
you can't know it without the black
without the white without the joy
and the pain and so
why is it such a screwed up system where
we have to
why do we have to be there what is like
what is the point i guess essentially
like what's the point of
us and it sounds like our dimension our
existence our
incarnation into earth and this meatsuit
and
you know is it to experience the duality
to realize oneness
is or what what is the point because if
oneness can't be necessarily realized
because it's the whole
[Music]
what the heck are we doing and is that
just supposed to be should we just
accept
we got to accept that it's going to go
up and down
or side to side but it's you see what
i'm saying like no no i get it i think
you articulate it pretty nicely which is
it
is through the duality that we get to
recognize the oneness not necessarily by
you know a visceral direct experience
although that is
also possible but i think by virtue of
what we're not
right in buddhism they use the
expression neti neti which is not this
not that so it's always this
sort of removal this discarding this
reconciliation
which is why i use the expression i
dissolve problems i don't solve them
most people have a problem they go and
see an expert
you know a psychiatrist a doctor a
psychologist a spiritual teacher
and invariably whether their anxiety
their addiction their depression their
finance issues their relationship
issues the conversation becomes about
the issue and then you come up with
strategies and solutions which is only
perpetuating the belief that the person
has a problem in the first place
whereas what i'm pointing out is the
problem only exists by virtue of the
fact that you think you are
somebody and that somebody is founded in
these deep narratives of inadequacy and
security and scarcity
and if we were able to reconcile those
and disintegrate the idea of yourself
then the problem that belongs to the
persona you think you are equally just
disappears
i'm not sure i could put it back end of
that let's re
say that again a little slower people in
the back
[Laughter]
dissolving the self yes okay so i would
assert that that really is to go back to
your
question the reason we're here we're
manifest in physical form
like spiritual beings having a human
experience we become identified with
this narrative that we declare to be
ourselves similar to what we were saying
about i am a religion i am this and when
they're not truths even saying i'm
depressed not a truth
and so the the reconciliation of that
identity
is true freedom when people ask me about
my main product which is freedom they're
like well what do you mean by freedom
what i'm speaking to is the dis the
disassociation the reconciliation the
removal of and
the the discarding of the idea of myself
so that it becomes the impersonal
experience where there's no longer this
eye that i become associated with so the
i that you were
referring to earlier like the
self-critic and we're so hard on ourself
and that would never be a friend of mine
that narrative that conversation is
nonetheless the persona that we think we
are
that i would assert you're in here
incarnated in form
so that you can reconcile learn to love
and therefore discard and transcend
which then introduces you to the world
of true freedom and liberation
which is emancipation or moksha which is
spiritual enlightenment where there's no
longer this i that is
in any way confining or limiting or
constraining my true potential which is
boundless
so good luck with that and relationship
everybody's going to be rewinding it
and go back again rewind go back again
listen unpack
because it's so you know it's so natural
it's so embodied for you that it flows
out really quickly
yes um but these concepts are deeper
they're just
they're obviously and i love that but
it's it's deeper and it takes a
new way of thinking and expanded way of
thinking perhaps
yeah um to really understand it because
you've got to like
feel it how the hell did you get so deep
because i love it you mentioned a shift
maybe it's
maybe going i don't know if we need to
go back to that or it needs to go
further back then
than than the shift that you alluded to
um
what some would call an awakening yeah
um so
start where it feels necessary for you
to explain
how you got to this understanding of
existence
yeah and i appreciate that and i i'm not
you know it's not lost to me the fact
that i do tend to download quickly and
i'm
you know i'm also understanding the
luxury of this is recorded so people do
you know so one of the things that i
hear
probably the most is like holy [ __ ] like
that blew my mind like even in
instagram stories blew my mind blows my
mind blow you know
like so i'm downloading by virtue of you
know the fact that that's how i speak
and also it carries a resonance that
makes people have to pay attention if i
were to speak in a regular sort of
monotone about this and anxiety
often times it occurs to somebody in the
way they listen as this i've heard this
before and they can check out
whereas they're like hang on a minute
i'm not quite sure what this guy is
saying but it's freaking uber profound
i need to show up so that's one of the
reasons that like even in my workshops
like we had a few comments like a couple
of thousand people on this workshop
which was so fun
and a couple of people like oh my god
this guy speaks so quick
and i'm like yeah see you have to
freaking pay attention
but the luxury part is you can rewind
and revisit
and you're always going to listen from a
different perspective by virtue of the
fact that you evolve when you hear
something you've never heard before
and then you will listen from a new
place so that when you revisit it
then you get to download so i don't want
to treat people so
literally the point of the show for me
literally is to plant seeds
so you can hear something for the first
time and then when you hear it for the
second time
that is when you go huh you know i've
heard this before
and it sits different because you've
already yeah
it's already in there yes yeah so so
that's
you know just to speak to the dynamic of
a podcast and being on youtube did you
learn to do that or is this natural and
you just realized that was the result
it was natural and i recognize you know
at a deeper level why it was occurring
that way
so there's it's like listening to music
you know like words are vibratory right
so really this is a vibrational universe
so beyond the words i'm using there's
also a tone that is coming through which
to your point about
wow this is so natural to you and
whether people actually picked up on
that
now they pick up on that because you
spoke to it but their resonance would
have picked up on that
so watching lebron james do whatever he
does or you know
uh naffa radal uh you know or like roger
federer uh
you know do what they do it's like it
looks effortless by virtue of the fact
that they've done it for so long so for
me now i've done this for over two
decades
so there is an effortlessness that can
be aspirational for people which is also
included in the unpacking and the
equation of how i'm helping people to
evolve
is that i don't want to break it down
like i'm a teacher because then i
also can become quite pretentious so i
really want to be a living example of
what is
already british so that just pretty much
gets you halfway there
exactly they're like wow this guy like
no i'm not
cause you mentioned something that i had
thought about and then you mentioned it
again so
i think we should just talk about it
because this has also been on my mind
okay and you mentioned frequency and you
mentioned resonance and all the stuff
and so
um all the things yeah all the things
we're gonna we're gonna touch all the
things today because we're talking fast
enough
yeah we're just gonna keep doing that
too that's what she said
um so i've been thinking so much about
frequency and the
basically the idea that the underlying
truth of a topic or a thought or a
person or an event
um that is your resonance that's the
frequency of the information
now the words that come out of your
mouth might not match
and to me this is part of this mask
that's worn
in the example i keep giving lately i
tend to spin on the same
example because it's really on my mind
but you know you hate your boss and
you're talking crap about
whoever him or her and they walk in
you're like hey good to see you how you
doing
well now this is a confusing dynamic
because you hate them right and you're
bothered by them but then you're like
good to see you
yeah so like we i think as a culture
are required to evolve and also
are stepping into living a life that's
more embodied and authentic
and doing things that we truly love to
do so we don't have to fake it right
yeah um but i just think it's an
important topic for people to hear
because i try and exist
imagining that everyone can read my mind
okay aka frequency yeah
right so like you have you can't you
can't be talking crap about things in
your head or thinking something
different than what you
say and so the emotional level of it and
in some of the interviews i just done
too it was like the intention
the feeling is really critical when
you're gonna
give a message to someone and have it
hit yeah right
or say something yeah even i love you
right yeah
it's like i love you or like i love you
like one or the other right like
i really felt that yeah i did i
literally put like the
the feeling of like a [ __ ] like a lot
you know but
people say it all the time it might not
be the intention might not be there
um so it could be anything yeah um so i
just think that this is an important
concept for people to actually realize
matters yeah it's huge i mean there's a
couple of things that i get from what
you shared one i'm curious why you would
for yourself because it's a bit of an
attell for me at least
about your relationship to yourself that
you would have the proposition
that people can hear what you're saying
in your head and that you would walk
around planet earth you know to whatever
varying degree you'd
slip in and out of that the that would
be
a perspective that you carry because you
know that to me sounds a little bit
self-defensive ironically it sounds at
one level very vulnerable
but equally it sounds very protective
because it
it becomes self it's a self-conscious
narrative right like so if you're
declaring well what if everybody could
hear everything in my head it's almost
like a discipline
or that you're somehow being reprimanded
in a way that you're
being self-auditing of your own thoughts
right does that make sense like and
you're going to have your own rationale
as to why you came up with that you
could equally have something more poetic
and
oh well no i want to be much more
conscious of the way that i treat people
and that equally could be a subtle
symptom of that so
so i'm curious to hear why you have that
and then secondly
and i love you the feeling
that comes across with words i would say
is truly
what lands more than words right like
human beings unfortunately one of the
predominant qualities of a human being
is pretense
is inauthenticity is lying and i think
that's become incredibly
evident with what's going on in the
world right now in politics and
corporations and pharma
and these tv experts like you know
people are fed up
like with the lies now unfortunately
it's a human dynamic so they also have
to look at themselves as opposed to just
pointing fingers and go okay where am i
in my own
little sphere my own garden and my own
family my own office where am i still
lying because lying is a form of
self-protection
the first time a child discerned the
fact that they were in trouble and it
didn't feel good because until that
point
a child a baby particularly doesn't know
anything other than full self-acceptance
because they don't know that what
they're doing is in any way like
socially unacceptable or wrong or bad
like
no you can throw up on a gucci dress
because you're a baby you can poop your
pants just after i just change them
because you're a baby like there's this
real sense of love and acceptance
but you get to a certain age around two
or three usually with the terrible twos
that you learn through language as
certain activities and behaviors are no
longer acceptable
and that's where we learn as human
beings the absence of
unconditional love and that hurts right
that's that beginning of the separation
from the womb that is my mom and my
family and so from that point we start
to learn pretense we start to learn to
lie because we now know
through self-referral that i got
reprimanded once for doing that before
so now that there's the implication that
i've been caught for it again i'm gonna
say no i didn't
and from that moment at age two so you
better believe that
you know whoever is this
multi-billionaire philanthropist to a
doctor to whatever they're talking about
they're just categorically lying not
because they're quote-unquote bad people
just because they don't know anything
different because that's what they've
done for decades and it's all about
self-preservation
with whatever their intention and agenda
is so
in the absence of lying we could say
there's vulnerability there's
transparency there's authenticity and
that
land's very different for a human being
so you could say no i love you or like
your point about the boss and
oh nice to see you like that's complete
bs
right but it's it's it's preservation
it's wanting to belong in an environment
where you
feel some sense of potential threat and
therefore i have to put on a facade in
order to make sure that my belonging
isn't jeopardized
because in primal fear when we when
we're chastised and we're kicked out of
the gang we don't survive
because the the gang is the the tribe
that lives in a cave and has got the
food and the fire
and if i'm excommunicated from that
group and i'm out there in the wild this
is primal dna
i'm not gonna make it right and so
that's still part of our
you know nervous system and so there's
going to be this partic this pretense
and the way that people make them up
literally psychologically emotionally
verbally
we will present ourselves our ambassador
and we see this all the time on you know
the first few dates you have with
somebody
it's like and then you end up living
with someone four months and they're
like what
whatever happened to the guy that used
to groom or like take care of himself or
be nice to me you know it's like
the facade has sort of run its course so
is there
so is there a place for it then maybe
there may be the is there a place for
lying
it's well it's present it's
self-preservation you know it might keep
you in a job so
i but it's still at the end of the day
it's still going to be to your
fundamental demise because until such
time that you're tapped into your
authentic value
then you know when you really get who
you are as a person
both in terms of your worth your
security your perspective of
belonging then there's no longer
anything to pretend
right because i'm part of the gang i
don't need like a black card
you know i don't need the vip status
right or status
that's the point and so to me that's the
point that's right for me about
going back to sort of like wondering
where that comes from
and uh is there a protection
going on to think that way about my
thoughts being a frequency that has been
able to be felt or acknowledged on a
subconscious or emotional
emotional body level yeah um it's more
about
uh using the experience to
clean it up yeah and so sometimes clean
it up might be
get out exit sometimes it might be
what does this say about me what does
this say about something some aspect of
myself that i haven't looked at yet
yeah that i haven't healed that i
haven't acknowledged that i'm denying
myself
so it's kind of more like a check system
of like
i know my underlying feelings that i'm
not expressing
carry weight yes and i think for you
there's an opportunity within that not
only like obviously i get your
commitment to how you show up for other
people which is beautiful and we could
maybe unpack that from childhood and
where did this little girl feel it was
incumbent upon her and how she showed up
we gotta go so it looks like the show's
over
and no i'm just kidding i'm totally in
the childhood
the childhood work yeah but i my guess
is with the little bit i know about you
that like as someone who cares that much
who's self you know aware who's done
what you've done in the world
that there were moments probably as a
little child which is not like you know
this isn't like radically different than
most people's
childhood where they felt it was
incumbent upon them in the way that they
showed up like
you upset mummy or you upset daddy
like who heard that or where's the
parent somewhat
codependent on their child because they
had a drinking issue or they were a
little bit like mercurial in their
emotions and the kid was like oh i
better behave and i've got to do
something to make sure that i keep the
peace
without knowing anything about your
childhood but that to me would be an
extension of that survival mechanism
which you feel it's incumbent upon you
that you have some sense of
responsibility towards how other people
feel yeah does that resonate sure okay
we got tissues yeah oh yeah get ready i
don't care i
actually come to a place where crying is
really good yeah like it's like i
i welcome in the tears of no i get
there's a release yeah no of course and
listen i'm playing with you you're
awesome
but that that mechanism you're awesome
yeah well more awesome
whatever that means you're whatever
so so being able to recognize and i'm
glad that resonates like you know you're
obviously a sweetheart but i would
wonder how that manifests in personal
relationships for you because oftentimes
for the feminine
there is a little extra pressure in the
way that the woman will become
increasingly tolerant
of the way that the man shows up almost
like
because of the nature of nurturing that
is very feminine
tending to hold a space that is beyond
something that is healthy
and this is something i help a lot of
women with where they're oftentimes in
relationships doesn't have to be
romantic could be family it could be
also business
because like the tendency is to want to
be nurturing because that's primal but
then over nurturing as a compensation
maybe for their own lack of
feeling of worth and it doesn't have to
be romantic it could be in families it
could be in the workplace where there is
this bandwidth that
that overextends itself so tolerance
becomes like a place where now it's no
longer healthy it's no longer authentic
it's a compensation it's a survival
mechanism
where the woman is doing what she feels
she should either because she sees
potential or she's being self-protective
she doesn't feel
safe she doesn't feel held by the
masculine and invariably
it's sad to say that is incredibly
commonplace and so
you know the degree to which you have
learned in yourself
just by virtue of maybe being in an
environment as a child that like
okay i don't want to do anything to rock
the boat i don't want to upset anyone i
don't want to do anything wrong i don't
want to be a bad girl these are all very
common narratives for children
that nonetheless manifest in adults
where it becomes a mechanism for
self-preservation so
your self-reflection which we could say
is beautiful and it really is
really speaks to me in a way that it
shows that you perhaps have become a
little bit too
responsible in the way that you think
you're accountable for other people's
wellness or their happiness or
so does that 100 accurate okay good i'll
keep up my day job yeah
um yeah yeah so now so then if we could
like just for a minute
like just because you're awesome the
fact that that's 100
accurate in the way that i'm speaking to
it about you
can you share how does that leave you
feeling just to bring a little extra
awareness about it
yeah um well the first thing that comes
up is that
you know i'm abandoning myself correct
uh
in doing super accurate i'm abandoning
really the inner child
yes um that uh it's in her child work
it's it's it's out of integrity i'm now
not in integrity
with myself yeah by abandoning myself to
take care of someone else yes even
though i think i'm doing it for
them and it's great and it's for me it's
not it's like i lose myself
and so for me that says that i don't
know my boundaries yet i don't have my
own personal boundary
which is something i had to learn a lot
about in the last year yeah
because i always thought boundaries were
for someone else like don't do that to
me
yeah and then what i realized at least
from from in my mind was that the
boundary was actually for myself like
how far i'm willing to go
yeah yeah and so that's the first thing
that comes amazing
beautiful it's super accurate and i want
you just to feel it so the abandonment
so even if you were to look at it third
person if you were to abandon someone
that you loved if you abandoned a
daughter a child
how would that feel for you yeah how
would you feel
knowing so beyond the expression of how
you might respond to the abandonment if
you abandon your child then of course
there's gonna be a natural
proclivity to come back towards them but
let's forget that for now if you
felt like you suddenly woke up and go oh
my god i've completely abandoned my
child
how would that hit you i don't think
i've ever
i don't think i've really gone there
before i don't think i've really ever
felt i'm just being honest like i don't
wouldn't do that right i understand but
this is also
beautiful because invariably when people
ask what are they going to get from
working with me i say you don't know
until you go through it so actually what
we're touching on is something that has
become
so normalized for you yeah yeah you
don't know how to access it which is
beautiful that means we're right up
against them yeah
because this is your world like i use
the expression i say if you were born
with blue tinted glasses on how would
life look to you
right how so through blue tint ever i
mean
everything would look everything would
look blue perfect right so now
this is the aha moment if you were born
with blue tinted glasses
nothing would look blue because that was
all you've ever known right
right right so that's the right so right
here right here what we're up against
is that you don't need to that i don't
know i have on yes
yeah beautiful but that's why i want you
to feel it especially as a woman because
women are much more
um available to their own emotions and
feelings this if you could feel like you
said that
you said it perfectly i've abandoned
myself in the process of trying to
protect myself it looks like i'm being
more considerate of the other person
which is actually about
self-preservation
going back to the child that didn't want
to get in trouble didn't want to upset
mom whatever it is and so actually
you're abandoning your
own self in the process of self survival
now once you see that there's got to be
some feeling of
something not like there has to be like
i'm forcing it but when you really wake
up and go wow
i have truly because without going
through every item of your
romantic relationships and where there
was hostility or there was hardship or
there was
you know derogatory ex at your expense
you know there was abuse of some form
and abuse is a big word but like it
could be the way someone spoke to you
like that's the abandonment of yourself
so if you can
you know if you could collapse all of
these experiences
there's going to be something there
right
and what what i mean i get i i think
you're right there's there's some
sort of imaginary wall between these
existences
of of me being able to truly feel it's
maybe this is it i don't know um this
is the process of
healing to be able to feel for the
abandoned child
abandon inner self yes the inner child
yeah like
if i'm if that's if being that way
and i said it's a i feel like that'd be
abandoning yeah what would it feel like
to
abandon someone you're asking that if i
could
create understand that feeling if i
could start to access that feeling i
would now
create the relationship with the inner
child because that's exactly what i've
done to it
yes and it gets a little deeper because
you're also the inner child so there's
not only the experience of a woman
who is denying her own needs her own
worth the way that people treat her
which is the abandonment of self but
there's the experience of that which is
abandoned within you
meaning the little girl so the mother
that she adores that she doesn't know
what she's done wrong
to feel abandoned by she also has an
experience
yes one of the things that i've done in
the last year to
um bridge that gap a little bit because
it seems easier like oh i can handle
crap i can handle being treated like
[ __ ] i can handle
all the whatever emotional abuse or
anything that's gone on
um is to imagine the way that someone's
treating me would i ever let them treat
my little girl like that yeah and i
imagine that to be my
inner child yes and so i somewhat
disassociate from it even though i know
it's me
yes it's easier to access the ability to
treat myself properly if i
imagine that it's a little girl in me
yes
of course and that's another protection
mechanism right so look at the words you
use like i can handle the emotional
abuse and whatever it is like
yeah and people might describe you it's
like i know she's awesome she's tough
would probably be a word and you look at
your career
and the fact that you're competing
against guys and in a sport that is
you know all of the things right like
that speaks to somebody whose persona
has become you know very robust but that
doesn't speak to what's beneath it
and that's what i'm like like picking a
way out very gently here and you're
doing a great job and i know it's a
podcast but
like you know there is this okay i'm
super open i know
it's not a no fear at all it's it's
beautiful so
so i still want to come back to what
does it feel like because you know
there's a little bit of like deflection
here
when you recognize that you have
feelings right and i'm not talking in a
woo-woo kind of kumbaya
but you're a sentient being you're a
woman you know and an extraordinary
woman and an
accomplished woman and a caring woman
and the degree to which all of that gets
kind of pushed to one side because you
can handle the abuse
as i tell people just because it's
familiar doesn't mean it's healthy right
totally yeah so so can you just
even if it's a word or two if you
recognize the degree to which you've
discarded
some of your own like care of self
what would that leave you feeling
to recognize well i have completely in
ways that is
not like your fault but it is your
responsibility is the way i said like
it's an unconscious process it's the
blue tinted glasses you didn't know
so you don't have to feel shame or guilt
but once you see it and go wow i've
really disregarded my needs
over and over and over like how does
that hit you when you really see it
like negligent like yeah
[Music]
abusive in the opposite way that i
express it yeah
right it's avoidant yeah it's
disassociative
yeah even though i express more on the
side of
codependency or or the anxious
attachment or the wanting or diving in
or
unpacking talking it's actually
inside of myself it feels like it
is the opposite side of the spectrum
which is the same hole
as we've kind of been expressing and it
would be like i've disassociated with
myself and so it feels
um that's why it's so hurtful because
that's exactly what i do to myself
there you go so there's a there's now
you've used a word that i want which is
it's hurtful
because all the words you're super
articulate but they're all they're a
little bit still from here up
right and i'm just wanting to get a
little bit closer to this thing which
you have a huge one on
but really that's the first glimpse
you've given me it's hurtful
like as much as you can say i can handle
the emotional abuse of whatever
boyfriend this
or a male dad or it doesn't even have to
be male but you get the point i'm sure
if i were a fly on the wall of your life
i would have witnessed a lot
that is hurtful mhm but you've learned
to protect yourself and be okay with it
even though you're not actually okay
with it energetically and
physiologically it will manifest in
different ways over time you know you're
still young and healthy
but over time that's what becomes
dis-ease
you know manifest physiologically
because of the absence of ease in our
system because we're actually hurt
and hurts bedfellow is also fear scared
yeah so that little girl who's protected
herself by virtue of becoming tough and
resilient is actually
hurt and scared she's hurt from a past
event that was tough
and now she's scared of its repetition
so
hurt is great can you find like where
they might be the scared
and the fear the concern the anxiety the
apprehension
sad sad for sure uh
worthless yeah worthless is very you
know it's a it's an adult way of saying
like there's a feeling of like i'm not
special i'm not loved i'm not wanted
yeah yeah yeah but all of that belongs
to that little girl
yeah so you're doing awesome yeah um
unimportant
like you know kind of the somewhat of
the inner child work that i've done
associating with her um
is that she was like i'm gonna be really
descriptive it's gonna be
sounds pretty maybe weird to people yeah
um maybe not to you because you've
probably heard everything
but i imagine that this inner child the
little girl in me was like it was as if
she was like
sorry i have to close my eyes but it's
very visual for me um it's like
up in a tower like a dome and she was
inside of the dome and it was like a
concrete dome with like just a
tiny little hole to see the light and
there was no access there was like no
getting to it it was like you know
there's some
childhood fictitious story right about
being up in the tower yeah
and then later on she came down and it
was as if she was at the bottom of the
tower now and she was like standing at
the doorway
um but still quiet always really quiet
no words
yeah because like there it was almost
the feeling i got from it was that there
was no
it didn't matter anyway like there was
no point there was nobody was listening
right um and then it was as if she
finally got
taller and like stood next to me um
and then i had a recent experience where
i was
looking to talk to her as i talked to my
higher self my inner child
my soul whatever you want to call it
yeah um
and she has her name her name is lucy
and i went to go talk to her and she was
like
uh she i said i hadn't talked to you in
a while how you doing and
i know this probably sounds so weird to
people but then she was like that's okay
we're merging and i was like
what and then all of a sudden she goes
but you can talk to me anytime you want
just like this
and then all of a sudden this other
aspect somewhere else
says this is oneness like true oneness
is the
embodiment of your higher self or your
soul or your inner child or whatever you
want to call it
with the you so that you're totally
embodied in
in your in your life every day
how you live it what you say how you
feel yeah
anyway so that's been like the evolution
of
my inner child work so far beautiful and
very powerful images right like you look
at some of the things like so
height like extended away from the
ground like you're separated
concrete is the word you use it's not
like it was a dome that was made of
linen concrete so there's a level of
protection and isolation
and the second law of thermodynamics
speaks to any isolated object is by
virtue of the fact that it's isolated
you think of like in a
correction facility they put them in
solitary confinement that is the
ultimate form of isolation
and there is going to be this
deleterious effect over time you start
to lose your mind you know have no sense
of belonging so this is where the hurt
is and where
you also gave a huge a tell when you
said you know and she came down and she
was she didn't have anything to say she
was very quiet
and you said because what's the point no
one's going to listen anyway
that speaks to the dismissiveness that
she experienced right
and there's no value there there's no
sense of importance there's no sense of
love like i'm not curious to hear what
my child has to say is the experience
right now you're starting to feel it and
this is like the mom that i spoke of at
the hawaii
retreat where she wasn't listening to
her son she was at least doing a
better job superimposing her version of
superiority or love to
upon him but he still wasn't being
gotten yours was obviously very
different where
as often the case children are to be
seen and not heard
so that you know i see a little bit of
water behind the eyes where you can see
perhaps now wow that little girl was
really just disregarded
it's one thing to not be loved it's
another thing to feel not wanted
very similar but they're very powerfully
different because not being loved is one
thing
not being wanted has got a form and an
energy of disregard
it's removing you can be there and not
be loved
but if you're not wanted then you
actually feel displaced
now that's a different breath right so
there's something energetically that
just got released
so that i'm guessing is going to be part
of your experiences that at times that
little girl who i guarantee you is a
sweetheart
very shy very creative very sensitive
but felt the experience of not being
wanted is my guess
yeah this is actually like i mean again
it's super honest but
this has been actually i always thought
it was my dad that i was getting all the
problems from
but it's my mom yeah that's what i was
picking up on
i mean just in recent experiences of
like things that have gone on
and oh no i'm going to cry on tv yeah
it's beautiful but it was like
okay this is beautiful like i realized
that
this is the wound like i've had to have
my own back
my whole life because my mom would just
watch my dad yell at me and she would
never say anything
and here i am at 38 and i'm still like
i still need love right it's not
different
now than it was before it's just i can
see it now
yeah and so i was like wow you know like
my dad was hard on me
so i found guys that were hard on me and
then i abandoned myself
yeah which is exactly what my mom like
would do to me emotionally and it's the
thing is
is that it's actually not her fault
it was her upbringing yeah and i
remember asking her this summer i was
like
are did you ever get to have feelings as
a kid and she was like no
no so i know it's not even her fault but
this is the problem right this is the
pattern of
this is where you have to break the
cycle right is that
someone has to stop doing the same thing
that's been done to the their parents
because it's done to them
yeah right yes yeah before i answer your
question
i just want to say thank you like really
this means a lot to me
like that you can feel safe enough to go
here
and we would like like skirting the edge
there for a while right
and you you you know i don't want to
sound cheesy but you're so beautiful
in all of this right and i want you to
really hear that and it's going to be
reflected i'm sure
like thousands of times by people who
witness the bravery and the courage of
who you're being right now because
everybody's got their version
so i feel super flattered and honored
that i could be
a man holding a space for you in this
beautiful expression of what's really
real for
you and the neglect that has been there
through no one's fault this is not about
your mum being a bad person
she was doing the best she could what's
her what's what's her name first name
bev so bev was doing the best she could
within the level of her awareness and
conditioning
right so that's why there's no fault
there is nonetheless the impact
of her inability to hold space to
protect her own child
what i want you to recognize is you
became your mom
right so the neglect that you experience
is the language that you learned in the
way that you speak of the fact that you
could
tolerate any kind of abuse and you just
said it like the men that you would
attract
have to reflect it looks like it's a
mirror of your father which in the male
female dynamic it is going to be right
because that's what you're
comfortable with like i said earlier if
people remember i said just because it's
familiar doesn't mean it's healthy
yeah but it's familiar now why this is
so beautiful and why i feel so
privileged to be able to hold a space of
love and acceptance for you and to be
able to articulate language so that we
can penetrate this
is that now you literally get to be a
different woman and as you said you get
to change this sort of genetically
inherited this
emotionally inherited this pattern
inherited
that you now can become a woman who
recognizes the importance of making
space for another
now ironically you are doing it
strategically is like you're aware of
your thoughts and your resonance and
your frequency
so you were doing it but that was a way
of surviving it wasn't authentic
authentic is actually making space for
your negative thoughts
because then you make space for the
other person's negative thoughts making
space for your heartfelt feelings
see it's the opposite it's ironic the
intention is the same
but love is the container for all of it
whereas you were being the
perfected the curated child in the way
that you had to behave you had to
tolerate you had to be tough
okay i'm gonna have a boyfriend who's
gonna be broth but it's okay i can
handle it
so if we want to go back full circle and
why this conversation is so profound for
people who are tracking at home
is because your incarnation as far as
i'm concerned
is so profound because it's for you to
recognize
what does it mean to truly come from a
position of love that includes you
because you've loved but as i say often
to women love
occurs to them as they put their arms
out and they embrace everyone even in
the face of abuse like physical
verbal sexual whatever but no i must
love more and oftentimes that is the
antidote right it's like oh maybe i'm
not loving enough i have to love more
and then it becomes exhausting
whereas what i want you to understand is
love not just your arms around the world
and everybody is important to you
but love has arms around you
also a physical action i've done in the
last year too
like literally this yeah like holding
like not metaphorically literally but
implying the metaphor of holding myself
yeah amazing what a what a powerful
moment
to share with you i'm so so blessed so
now what now we can access a little bit
more of the feeling because we saw it
right so not only is it sad it's hurtful
it's scary but there's a feeling also i
would want you to look at and i'm not
going to leave the witness here but it's
tiring
you know it's exhausting because that
little girl that you're trying to
compensate for in the manner with which
you withhold and you withstand
abuse or the fact that you try to go
above and beyond for other people
is itself exhausting no yeah can you see
that yeah
well again usually what happens is that
you put out
put out that say so it's more powerful
uh i put that energy out for so long
that eventually
i feel i can feel the underappreciation
yeah
nobody asked for how much i was doing
but
i guess maybe i'm under-appreciating
myself so i'm feeling under-appreciated
yeah because i'm giving more than is
even asked
yeah so the quote that i just put up on
my instagram
recently you know says until you love
and respect yourself what makes you
think anyone else should
and that's a hard thing for people to
swallow now i'm not saying that people
couldn't love you you know i might
change it to
until you love and respect yourself what
makes you think anyone else will
you know because the energetics that you
have
the dismissal that you experienced
through your mum was a perfect energetic
mirror for the soul incarnation that you
have because that's what you've been
doing to yourself
totally and then you had the audacity no
fault and i'm using a big word but
you know to think it was because of her
okay well you're looking at bev
god bless her doing the best you can but
you have for decades been doing the same
thing to yourself
totally exactly and then hypocrisy
right but now it's a blind spot so
there's no blame for either of you but
now there can be that joyous laugh of
like wow that's just ridiculous
right like i'm looking for other people
to give me the reassurance the love the
affection the value that i don't give
myself
right good luck with that
so now for the first time ever i'm going
to make a bold statement
you actually have available to you the
possibility of love that you've never
experienced before
from other because you're learning to
find that for yourself what a gift
to not just to yourself but to them too
because now they get the capacity to
love
in a way that they didn't know was
available to them and i don't think
there's a greater gift you can give
someone than the ability to help them
see how loving they can be but as long
as you're too busy protecting yourself
and you're okay with
the rough and tumble of what's going on
because you've become accustomed to it
again familiar not healthy
tolerance now you know there's no room
for anyone to really love you because
you're not actually available to
because you're too busy protecting
yourself and having the narrative that
you don't actually deserve it anyway
because that's what you became
accustomed to that was the language
driving you
this is work that almost like nobody
does thank god it's becoming more
familiar though
yes yeah do you think by the way
we're still sitting here and i'm we're
i'm going to tie you to that chair
we're going to get to your moment okay
um for sure because i want to hear that
because i feel like it will
it's um it's in very i mean very
intrigued to hear what that was
um but uh
do you think that that is what is going
to ascend our species
consciously is this ability to
access those wounds
heal yeah become whole i mean is this
part of our evolution as a species
i would assert it's the only reason
we're here you know like the way i've
the way i've stated in other podcasts i
said it's the only real game
in town the game most people play is
like i want to
amass a little bit more wealth i ideally
want to get a bit more status
you know get a little bit more prestige
i want to have a bigger home
that's the human game but the real game
is spiritual evolution and that's why
you will constantly attract as i said
the people and circumstances to trigger
that part of you that we just very
beautifully revealed
until such time that you break out of it
and you get out of this concrete dome in
your case and you come down and play
and you share and you love and if things
hurt you don't engage you know if
somebody doesn't recognize your worth
and you don't engage like they may be
doing the best they can it doesn't have
to be judgment
but you recognize their hurt is now
being reflected
and that's not something that you have
to tolerate anymore which is just
beautiful for you like literally
again it sounds a little bit grandiose
but by virtue of the fact that you have
energetically just with me
reconciled relinquish some of this deep
pain
yeah the world just became a healthier
place
now do you get that energetically
because again going back to the
entanglement theory that everything is
interconnected
then if you have eight billion people on
a planet of which five billion are in
pain and that's generous you know it's
probably seven point nine
a billion are in pain but the fact that
you just nudged a needle towards an
energy of love and acceptance and
reverence
is itself healing for everybody yeah and
that's beautiful
yeah can i ask you a question yeah how
do you feel in your body do you feel a
little
like when i pointed out that breath
there was a release but you feel a
little lighter do you feel a little
more relaxed do you feel yeah i feel
hopeful okay i feel hopeful i feel
um brave yeah
i think you see a different opportunity
with bev yeah
this is a little early so i'm rushing
the process a little bit just because
you're a big processor but
um so what could you see as the
opportunity prior
you know we'll call it you know pc
before bc
[Music]
after vc well
yeah um before corrupt being before
being chroned bc
oh before chrome bev and chrome they
both go together
yes um so before there was obviously a
certain narrative that you carried like
i said the relationship of bev
is in you not over there yeah so you
were carrying a particular dialogue
about oh yeah
yeah so now i can see her for that now i
can meet her there
yeah so what would have been so that the
audience can follow because they're
going to i promise you have their
version of bev where they're making
someone wrong in their life so i'm
leading you a little bit but
you were in ways that you didn't perhaps
know were making her wrong there's an
underlying judgment energy so how do you
think that feels for bev
to be judged yeah like she probably has
to be protective
she's probably i'm sure yeah yeah yeah
and it just doesn't feel good right yeah
wronged by somebody right especially her
own daughter i think my dad said she
said sorry like
three times in their marriage and
they've been married since 1980.
yeah so yeah so like again in terms of
breaking that lineage
you know you get the opportunity maybe
be the one to say sorry
yeah which seems completely juxtaposed
to the way that you were viewing it
before which is bev was the perpetrator
and you were the victim but what if bev
didn't know to do that because bev's
functioning within the realm that's
available to her sure
that's different isn't it yeah we're
going real deep oh these are these are
all the really lake deeper
which is the roots like this is the
implied roots of the problem
right yeah well white spout and it's now
i give her access to being able to
feel what i've just felt essentially on
some level
so you get to not only break the lineage
of this pattern of dysfunction but you
also get to reverse time like you know
time reversal symmetry going in both
directions past and future
so you also get to help her heal from
her heritage
yeah in a way that she's never had
someone show up for her because it's
always been her fault that's all she
knows and she feels it from her own
daughter
so she's isolated she's got her concrete
dome
and you get the opportunity as a bigger
being that you are now by virtue of the
fact that you just literally expanded in
front of everybody
to hold a space of real love which isn't
about like victimhood
because what you were saying which is
the pretense is a lie is that i'm a
victim of bev's behavior
and that diminishes you and it also
holds her accountable to something she
could never be accountable for
that's powerful drop the mic there isn't
one but you can drop it
[Laughter]
drop the mic and pick up a blanket
that's so good
i'm not gonna cut that out either that's
just so important for people to like
hear that process yeah and hear what you
do
i mean and hear what's possible thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today i hope you enjoyed
it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button